no let's go let's go without the English
and well we're going to be transposing
army or well black has a decision c5
could still be played enter benoni black
gets to choose ok so this is officially
Queens gambit declined and well Bishop
here and I hear no I Bishop g5 and what
else push up here Bishop here chop no
all right III support my center Bishop
wants to come out I want to be up on
this diagonal still ah i'm going to go
with the night f3 MN rook see one okay
yeah definitely night here right now
right here right now and maybe rook here
before Bishop d3 these are minor minor
why actually there might be a
possibility for what I'm gonna do this
might be the possibility for Queen side
castle so hang on I don't know if I want
a king side castle there might be
something with chopped push push open up
the H file has anybody seen that type of
wine before have that played against me
to get crushed I forget the exact moves
but something that with that idea
exploiting that this pond has moved and
using it as a hook to open up the G or H
file queenside castle would likely be
met with chop-chop be 5 be 4 C 5 in some
order pushing the minor pieces around
gaining space and inching closer
to these queenside ponds looking to open
up the a B C files
pawn takes pawn and then just to say
that I'm a scaredy-cat pawn takes pawn
avoid complications I could play my
Brooke here I can still keep this
tension for a little longer let's see
what am I candidate moves there's rook
see one there's Bishop d3 there's pawn
captures I don't really want to do this
because of b6 and then be 585 I don't
have enough I can't support stuff here i
think i'm going to just take yeah just
can take so let's see how black
recaptures what's it going to be fill me
in what's the scoop what's the plan here
what is that plan if night here I have
to be cautious about Bishop d3 there's
tension between these bishops i think i
am officially getting 0 out of this or
am I hang on a second no no no no no I'm
getting something I'm going to take this
night this looks really simplified
doesn't it it's because it is that's the
that's the statement of the week right
there right there that was the statement
of the week um well what I'm looking at
is still possibilities for me having
advantage because of what because of how
much because of my good Bishop versus
there maybe not so great for show what
about night here right now that's gonna
stop night there or is it no it's not
okay because if I plate not here not
here chop chop chop there's pawn push
exploiting the pin left six let's not do
that two minutes to about three minutes
now I'm going to do this centralized my
night and I'd like to get in b4 b5 the
classic minority attack are you familiar
with it should be you need to be like
takes bishop as a bishop going to back
up what is it going to go where does it
want to live Rick be one be four or Die
play Queen c3 with this move I'm
assuming this eight this a 5 move is
probably going to be best I think a five
is the best move here okay now i think
this is something that i will look back
on in reference because now similar to i
think the last game getting that a pun
involved making me work a little bit
harder to get this push in is going to
benefit black because now you know if
I'm getting in this be four move it
could have already been a position where
if I'm to get in be four that means this
rook would already have some play over
here I think Brooks see one no no no no
no no no no let's get out of the
nonsense I was going to play rook here
but after Bishop here I thought I can
come back with to f1 but then after the
bishop comes to f5 I have to come back
and we danced I don't want to dance you
got to go back and forth like that let's
let's not do that we just would be a
perpetual I think best-case scenario so
throw in to check just for fun that does
nothing don't do that flight square I'm
really not liking my position and I
think that if this move is played too
soon I'm not going to like and I'm just
not gonna like things so
ah I want to trade Queens can we trade
Queens oh I'm seeing something maybe
let's do this initially I was going to
play my queen here but after Bishop
there I just kind of scratched my head
and I don't know what to do what I'm
looking for right now is Queen d6
followed by Queen g3 I want the Queen's
off the board before I make this break I
think there's there starts to be too
many attackers against my king who's a
really lacking defense there's a rook
lift I mean there's already two pieces
over here and that's I'm kind of maxed
out like that's not the best phrasing of
it but that's about as much as I could
tolerate two pieces so now this is we're
exchanging here and now I believe this
is the correct idea open this up right
now or I'm still going to wait you know
there's no rush with that be five min
I'm gonna get a little bit more out of
it before the position opens up I'm have
a flight square and I think my king now
wants to come here i'm trying to get a
little bit more out of this position i'm
trying to get every little drop out of
it here before it blows open maybe even
rook c1 prep moves i'm prepping this
break it cannot be prevented but now be
six is maybe close to happening and also
rook here is maybe close to happening
too okay also I'm down on time and maybe
I shouldn't have my king like that shame
on me shame on me okay let's go I should
have pre moved that yeah I maybe maybe
going here with silly let's do this I
gotta watch out you better watch out
here g2 is on fire it's happening soon
g2 is going to get hit sad day g2 whoo
scarred the seventh right now let's take
care and then guard the seventh let's do
this
whoa whoa I'm gonna fall for me I feel
it I'm not pretty don't forget about g2
let's just trade can we trade queens
please come on what I do to deserve this
trade queens just guard here this is sad
but I'm gonna try it about trade queens
oh it's getting scary over here scary
tone it's definitely scary town over
here get right here before there's
tricky tactics trade queens trade queens
please can we just trade queens please
let me throw in a check I don't need a
babysitter over there anymore right here
my clean is defending stuff the Queen's
are off come over here defend stuff and
now target this point I don't have any
time though I got a pre move at a pre
move I got a primo of stuff pretty move
cream of i'm dropping upon I think clock
situation I got a pre move there's no
time to be thinking no time to be
thinking where are the primos where the
primos pre-move land pre-move land time
burner city wow did that get messy oh
man good game good game I think that was
our first time doing battle against one
another very good game let me go back
let me flip the board let me see about
this game cuz I didn't really get a
whole lot out of it my opponent did well
to just equalized and maybe maybe it was
because I helped maybe it was because I
helped you know our I released the
tension the center maybe I should have
done otherwise maybe I shouldn't have
been so scared about queenside castle
but wow okay anyhow we get into this
very quiet
position right here I think an
improvement make me struggle more to get
in be four that's one thing also what
else what else what else what else get
in a five also get in what I think keep
your light squared Bishop around I was
happy to see this exchange even though I
mean you eventually generated threats
against my king side g2 I was having to
babysit but keep that light square
Bishop around I think we're still
pressure though I get this break-in and
seems to be pretty even I mean this is a
weak link but you could be defending it
laterally and still keeping threats I
think I stood better soon as the Queen's
rauf just because of the this guy being
a weak point but we were in super fast
we're definitely blitzing or bulleting
out moves at that point so I don't know
I think the main thing is regarding the
particular pond move early on a 5 i'm
gonna have to work harder for that and
maybe avoid a particular exchange that
light squared Bishop maybe is a little
bit uh it's gonna be a little bit more
of an improvement all right good game
though that's got crazy right there at
the end